esta semana millones de hogares
mexicanos encendieron temprano su
televisor pero no para ver noticias el
aparato que el 93 por ciento de los
mexicanos tiene en casa estaba el
proyecto algo que nunca antes había
transmitido clases para cerca de 30
millones de estudiantes de escuelas
públicas que permanecerán cerradas al
menos hasta fin de año debido a la
pandemia pero esta primera semana ha
sido un caos para maestros estudiantes y
profesores en la televisión pues no
contamos con el sistema por ejemplo en
canales estoy dando cursos estos no
contamos con nuestros canales
el gobierno mexicano apostó por un
ambicioso plan educativo en línea en el
que se planteó grabar un programa
completo para todos los grados escolares
ya que según el instituto nacional de
estadística y geografía de méxico sólo
el 56 por ciento de los hogares tiene
acceso a internet pero aunque el
gobierno dijo haber capacitado a más de
un millón de profesores para esta
operación la falta de recursos de
algunos maestros y estudiantes y las
fallas en infraestructura y señal en
algunos de los territorios más alejados
despertaron las dudas sobre si el
programa funcionará en un país con cerca
de la mitad
habitantes en situación de pobreza y
ahora sí en casa pues va a ser peor la
cosa pero
a ver que aprendiendo pero si como que
si da tristeza que pobres niños no
puedan ir a la escuela algunos expertos
señalan que estos obstáculos podrían
disparar la tasa de deserción escolar
una preocupación que parece estar
respaldada por la onu que advirtió que
méxico podría retroceder a un promedio
de 13 años de escolaridad por persona
debido a la pandemia